david hasselhoff walks into a bar
every morning and then he stays there
until it closes
a woman gets into a really bad car
accident the man rushes from work over
to the hospital the doctor comes out he
goes sorry
it's really bad news your wife was in a
horrible car accident her face and body
are totally mangled i shall be crippled
and paralyzed from the neck down
uh she's she's gonna need a 24-hour care
of which your insurance is not going to
pay for you're going to have to wash her
and feed her and keep turning her over
in case she gets bed sores and rubbing
ointment on her and you'll have to
change her pretty constantly because
she'll have no control over her bladder
of bowels and the man breaks down crying
and the doctor goes i'm just [ __ ]
with you she's dead
[Applause]
come on everyone take it easy on seth
it's gotta be hard for him to do a roast
especially because the simpsons haven't
done it yet
pam anderson is walking on a beach she
stumbles upon a magic lamp she rubs the
lamp a genie pops out
and the genie says i'm here to grant you
one wish pam says i want you to make vip
the hit show it should have been
the genie says even with all my power i
can't do that how can i grant you a
different wish
so pam says
okay
can you make my vagina tight again
and the genie says
let me take another look at vip
you know i'm old enough to remember back
to simpler more innocent times
when the worst thing you'd hear about
the news was hijacked jetliners
flying into buildings oh now gilbert
you're gonna get into trouble again
oprah winfrey goes to a doctor for a
checkup yes ah the doctor says okay
remove all your clothes she takes off
all her clothes he goes get on your
hands and knees she gets on her hands
and knees he looks at her and he goes
okay now crawl to the middle of the room
she crawls to the middle of the room and
goes now crawl over to that wall she
crawls over that wall he's looking at
her and then she crawls the yellow he
tells a crawl to that wall he's looking
at her and she goes doctor what's wrong
he said nothing i just bought a black
couch i can't decide where to put it
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you know i knew where that one was going
yes
a guy walks into a bar joan rivers is
the bartender he sees a sign over the
bar that reads cheese sandwich a dollar
fifty hand job ten dollars he says to
joan rivers are you the one that gives
the hand jobs joan says yes i am he says
well wash your hands [ __ ] i want a
cheese sandwich
a drunken farmer stumbles upstairs into
his bedroom waking his wife roseanne
she sits up and sees her husband holding
a sheep under his arm
the farmer yells this is the pig i've
been [ __ ]
roasting says you idiot that's not a pig
it's a sheep the farmer yells shut the
[ __ ] up i was talking to the sheep
david hasselhoff is running on the beach
in slow motion
he stumbles upon a magic lamp he rubs
the lamp but genie pops out
and says i'm here to grant you one wish
david says can you make baywatch nights
the hit show it should have been
then genie says i've seen baywatch night
and even with all my power i can't make
that show any good
you'll have to pick a different wish so
david thinks and says can you make
pamela anderson's vagina tight again